bonsoir à tous c'est norman et steffi
salut je parle super fort pourquoi parce
que pour aucune raison on actuellement à
l'avant-première de ce film paranormal
activité qui sort le 30 janvier
c'est vraiment cool en fait c'est une
caméra wi soient vagues ça fait les amis
nous crée pas senti moment ensemble mais
samatan à l'amour de l'amitié
je peux mais des vidéos de norman via
internet
les drôles et on aime bien ces vidéos on
tourne que des six hôtesses j'aime bien
son humour ça c'est le nouvel ibiza st
on se reconnaît un peu par rapport à lui
en fait un bel humour gêne donc et on
aime bien s'attendait pas à autant de
monde effectivement on pensait pas que
normal elle est autant d'après
complications la jeunesse c'est un
bonhomme voilà comment ces stocks chez
moi j'ai une kalachnikov
j'aime bien jouer des personnages via
dégueulasse effectivement j'ai eu à peu
près de 1580 sont plus conscients
verdict est parce qu aux grands défis
le fait que dans ma joue dans le film
aussi dans ses skis c'est un peu pour ça
que tu venu à la base et
le truc qu'il avait bien géré dans le
film c'est lui le patron comme il le dit
la manie toujours
une blague à la minute pendant tout le
film j'étais derrière donc c'est très
fraises c'est vraiment un film pas très
normal quoi j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'ici stade et trouve ça très normal
c'est juste on dit patrick normand très
bon dédia très bon chez nous chez soi
moi j'ai trouvé ça cool génial non
ouais vraiment l'air grave bien non
franchement j'aime bien éclaté ce matin
au génial c'était super c'est totalement
faux
honnêtement j'ai rigolé mais
quoi